So, we're familiar with the problem.
Zero connectivity is a bad experience,
low connectivity is,
well maddening and previously there
was nothing you could do about it.
All you could do is make a request and
then it's entirely out of your hands.
It might work, it might not,
it might be fast, but it might not.
You have zero control until
the request succeeds.
If it even succeeds.
Well, that story changes with
a relatively new browser feature
called service worker, and that's-
>> Wait, Jake.
>> What?
>> Was that it?
>> Was what, what?
>> This is the feature
that solves everything,
the feature that gives developers
new powers over the network.
You could at least introduce
it a bit better than that.
>> How do you mean?
>> Well.
>> For too long, users have been
left staring at a white screen.
For too long, they've been let down by
the cruel seas of network connectivity.
And for
too long we've been powerless to help.
[MUSIC]
We've been left waiting.
But no longer.
[MUSIC]
A new browser feature has arrived.
A total game changer.
[MUSIC]
A feature that let's you control
the network rather than letting
the network control you.
Who is this new feature?
What promises does it bring?
Introducing The Service Worker.
[MUSIC]
>> Yeah okay, that was pretty good.
I'm British you see.
I'm physically incapable of positivity
and excitement.
>> Well, I still like you,
Britishness and all.
>> Well, thank you.
>> And listen, if that wasn't compelling
enough for you to stick with us for
the next lesson, I don't know what is.
So strap in and
click through to the next lesson.
Let's drag the web into
the world of offline first.
>> Yeah, what he said, let's do this.